Itisatimefora­hatreatmale.QuickreminderaboutAtria.Mail.
Becauseifyouareapro­life,youdeservethedeathpenalty.
ThethreemaleitbypatriotswhohateDavidBatmanbecauseAmerica...Andbecause,freedom,
thisisIguessthisispseudo­leftHare.ATmalemaybeinsomesense.Let'stakealistentoithere,
packetweDavidchilledmeterisoffthecharts.I'msorry,David.Likealmosteverythingyousay
you'reclearlywrong,allthetime,"carefulwhatyoushallforDavid.Youmayendupregrettingit
whentheytakeyourmoney.YoumadethesilencingofTulsiarealityyoumadeisVianWarren
supportsdo­evenheck,man,he'sachillforthedemocraticestablishmentandA­I­P­A­C,andhe
hasareallybadpoliticalanalysis.
Listenguys,toseaceilingisliterallytwotothreepercentokay,toseewaspullingoneto2%for
months.YangotoutMayorPetegotoutAmy"colobusgotoutElizabethWarrengotout.
Andtoolsisstillpullingtwoto3%.Tullylostyesterdaytopeoplewhoaren'tevenrunning
anymore,insomeofthestates.
TheideathatIoranyoneelsesilencedherandwereitnotforus,hertheappealofherideaswould
havebeensooverwhelmingthatshewouldhavewonanything,isabsolutelyridiculous.Thisisthe
typeofdelusionalnonsensethatjusthurtsthemovementanditdistractsfromgettingthingsdone,
whichismypriority.RememberthatyoucanfightpatriotismwiththecouponcodeHareat40Tite
yousave40%,offofthemembershipofyourchoiceandHAtreatscrybecausetheirpatriotic
pleaseareignoredandsupportfortheDavidpackman.Showgrows.